so Naomi lovely to get a chance to
interview you on a book I just found
fantastic I read it really I think in
one long sitting and found it absolutely
fascinating and my first question to you
is how in the world were you able to
write this so quickly because you
reference things that just happened in
april/may and the book just came out
yeah well thank you so much Madea it's
great to speak with you I'm glad that
you enjoyed the book yeah I mean it was
it was a bit of a frenzy writing this
book I usually takes about five years to
write books that that's been my average
I published a new book about every seven
years I hope I give myself a little
break between about five full years this
book I I just I would just wanted to get
it out as quickly as possible
you know there's a there are a couple of
chapters in the book that are focused on
what we should expect if there is a
crisis in the United States if there's a
an economic crisis or a major security
crisis and I felt so passionately that
that there needed to be some political
disaster preparedness among progressives
that I that I that I just wrote it a
speed I frankly never written before and
and I also worked with a publisher that
was really committed to getting it out
really quickly too because you know the
pub the publishing industry can be quite
slow usually you know you finish the
book and then it's sort of you know
creeps along the production process and
all of these stages for you know and
another four months and in this case
everybody just worked so hard to get it
out in record-breaking time so I'm
really lucky to work with a publisher
who is as committed to the you know to
get to this political moment as I am I
think it's a great contribution to
millions of people who are looking
at our political situation right now in
thinking what do I do and obviously from
the title of the book you give it away
that no is not enough but I also see the
book as an amazing coming together of
your work that begins with the no logo
and the branding into the Shock Doctrine
and even with your climate work about
this changes everything it seems like
you are the quintessential anti-trump
and that you were really embodies
everything that is the opposite of what
Trump stands for so maybe we should
start with what you start the beginning
of the book which is looking at Trump as
the quintessential branding yeah and and
and the truth Midea as you know is that
so many of us have been on on this
journey you know some of my early work
as a journalist before I'd published any
books at all was focused on what I would
describe as the the underside of
branding focused on what's beneath the
the shine of behind those those
beautiful logos and and and and
transcendent marketing your marketing
got better and better in the 1990s it
sort of turned into high art you know in
the era of Nike and Michael Jordan but
behind those you know as as as companies
upped the ante and marketing and design
they really divested from the world of
work they sold off their factories they
started outsourcing to a web of
contractors and subcontractors and
giving contracts to whoever was willing
to produce their products as cheaply
cheaper and I say we've been on this
journey a long time because of course
your work at global exchange in the 90s
was part of this process of exposing the
horrific conditions under which some of
the most valuable brands in the world
Nike Disney were making their products
right so I look at I look at Trump of
this holo brand and by holo I mean you
know one of these companies that adopted
this paradigm we are not in the product
business right this was what this was a
big shift that I was tracking and no
logo was it you know it used to be
really up until the 80s that that you
know the iconic brands in the American
marketplace were manufacturers first in
aid product and then they branded those
products with logos and they marketed
them but in the 90s the order flipped
and you started to see companies
announcing that you know they they were
marketers first they were in the ideas
business and they projected their big
idea onto as many extensions of their
brand as possible and started building
these sort of self-enclosed branded
cocoons yeah Nick Disney in this period
opened a branded town celebration
Florida so you could live inside your
your favorite brand and Trump did this
in real estate he started off as a
pretty traditional real estate developer
but but quickly went into this this
stratosphere of these super brands and
the apprentice was an enormous
breakthrough for him where it became
less about building buildings and more
about building his brand and then
selling his name his brand for very high
prices to other developers who wanted to
have that Trump name on the side of
their condo tower on the side of their
resort and like those other brands that
I mentioned earlier this came at the
often at the expense of workers we've
heard many stories of terrible
conditions for workers and Trump owned
properties and also making Trump or
Ivanka branded clothing around the world
so here you have a guy who can make
millions of dollars in one building just
by allowing them to put his name on it
and then he becomes president and as you
say in the book it's impossible to
really separate out Trump and Trump and
his family and the family businesses
including of course Ivanka's
clothing line and the president now so
groups that are trying to I don't think
they can separate it Medea no I don't
think Trump knows where he where his
personal identity and then his
commercial brand begins he well I love
the aligning in the book
you can't disentangle Trump the man from
Trump's a brand those two entities you
say merged long time ago every time he
sets foot in one of his properties a
Golf Club a hotel a beach club the White
House press corps in tow he is
increasing his overall brand value which
allows his company to sell more
memberships rent more rooms and increase
fees so yes how could you possibly
separate this man from the brand and you
know the particulars of Trump is you
know he enters politics not playing by
the traditional rules of the game but
playing by the traditional rules of
branding and the only rule of branding
is stay true to your brand so in the
1990s you know there many activists
exposed that companies like Nike and
Disney were betraying the promise of
their brand which maybe was empowerment
for girls or you know a family friendly
and kid friendly ethos because their
products were being made under
conditions that were abusive to young
people in those factories and so they
were vulnerable on that print front and
they had to be responsive but Trump is a
really different entities a different
kind of brand because the big idea that
Trump has always sold was the idea of
absolute power through wealth this was
the promise of the Trump brand since the
eighties since he published his first
brand extension which was the art of the
deal he was selling the promise that you
can be a kind of a you know he loves the
word killer he doesn't mean it literally
but just you know somebody who's just
out for themselves willing to step on
anyone when he describes the art of the
deal it's really essentially about
screwing over other people and ending up
on top you know not coming to any kind
of mutually beneficial agreement
and and so he's the guy who gets away
with it and and he he has a consumer
base that wants to be him that has an
aspirational identity with him at a
consumer base that feels that they have
lost power on many different fronts and
Trump represents the the attainment of
the kind of power that they want and
that's a real problem when it comes to
holding Trump accountable to his brand
promise right you if you catch him lying
if you catch him cheating you know if
you catch him being nasty you know any
any things that might hurt a traditional
politician or even a brand that whose
brand identity had sort of more ethical
aspirational components Trump is not
hurt by any of this because it all
confirms his identity as the guy who
gets away with anything because he's so
rich so you know this is this is this is
a challenge the only way you can really
hurt the Trump brand is by is by proving
that he's not as powerful as he seems to
be this is why he's very bothered when
people talk about President Bannon or
the idea that he's the strings are being
pulled by Putin that hurts his brand
identity because his brand identity is
all about being the boss and this word
emoluments that I don't think most
Americans ever heard of before but is
now being bandied about moisturizer yeah
but now that there are lawsuits in court
trying to say that Donald Trump is
making money illegally from the
presidency by I don't know if it's just
foreign entities is it just foreign
entities like governments of Saudi
Arabia and others taking rooms and
renting up his hotels as part of
ill-gotten gains do anything do you
think there's anything to that is that
really illegal it may well be and it's
been interesting timing with the release
of the book because just as the the book
came out actually the day the book came
out the the news came that the attorneys
general of DC and also Marylin
had launched this lawsuit alleging a
violation of the Constitution on those
grounds and then a hundred and ninty
lawmakers and Congress filed a lawsuit
of their own and that one is really
significant because what the
Constitution says is that the president
cannot do this without the permission of
Congress right so the people who are
that there they're there already was a
lawsuit that had been filed by a DC
restaurant I believe and also a group of
restaurant workers who were making this
allegation but the significance of
Congress people filing their own-
lawsuit is that they are the ones who
should have been consulted right so they
really have the most legitimacy as a
party it would seem to to make this
challenge and and and you know we may
well discover that Trump is not as
immune as he thinks he is and it has
been behaving as if he is and one thing
I would just add Madea is that a lot of
the examples we've heard for how he's
receiving gift may be receiving gifts or
benefits from foreign governments have
focused on these hotel rooms and you
know and I think there is a case to be
made that foreign governments are
deciding to stay at the Trump Hotel
deciding to have expensive events at
Trump properties to ingratiate
themselves to the president and
hopefully you know get into his good
graces there's other but there are other
things to look at as well including the
fact that the Chinese government has
been granting a wave of trademarks to
both Trump and Ivanka to sell their
products in China what I am most
disturbed by something that I don't
think has gotten nearly enough media
attention which is that the that the
Chinese government has detained labor
monitors who were investigating
conditions in one of the velka's
factories that would seem to me to be a
very tangible benefit and I think the
allegation is not that these governments
are being directed to do this by Trump
it's that they see that this
president has not divested and they
believe that these are favors that they
can do to get themselves into the good
graces of a president who is clearly
clearly very very concerned about his
personal and family wealth right so you
don't need to prove that you know Ivanka
is on the phone going arrest those
people no that's not the allegation the
allegation would be that the Chinese
government you know would think that it
would be a helpful thing to do to get
rid of those pesky whistleblowers well
one of the points that you make in the
book is that this is not anything new
that you talked about the decades that
the Clintons had been using their
foundation as a place where people could
give money to curry favor with them so I
wonder if you could tell us a bit about
how the stage was set for Trump right
and this is you know it's s my
overarching goal in writing the book
other than getting it out before there's
a major crisis was to try to challenge
this you know I think this narrative
because Trump is so unlike any kind of
any president before there is this idea
that he kind of is a Martian you know
that sort of stormed an otherwise
functioning system and if he could only
be impeached then everything would be
fine
and you know I'm not saying that you
know that's nothing one way or another
on impeachment obviously if he's
committed impeachable offenses you
should be impeached but that will just
get us where we were before Trump and
that was the ground that created Trump
it was not a safe place it's nothing to
prevent somebody else who combines an
even more dangerous mix of these
qualities that Trump has from from
taking power once again
and so yeah and I see this is very much
a bipartisan process that the table that
was set for Trump and it you know it
isn't just about politics it's about
media it's about news coverage the table
was set for him in so many ways that all
he needed to do is just show up because
it was sort of weed art we were already
treating elections like reality TV shows
we already had a media landscape that
was much more interested in
interpersonal dramas between candidates
than in in-depth coverage of the issues
we already had Democrat Democrats using
the tools of corporate branding
themselves President Obama was a
fantastic brand he used incredibly
cutting-edge marketing techniques and
you know a lot of us felt that there was
you know that behind the claims that he
was leading this you know deep change
and transformation that there wasn't
enough change and that that also helps
at the table for for Trump something
else that set the table for Trump I
believe was this liberal idea that the
Clintons were really central to which
which was all about how billionaires
could use the great wealth that they
amassed in the period of deregulation
and privatization to fix problems that
we traditionally look to governments to
solve so if you look at the Clinton
Global Initiative and and you know you
mentioned that currying a favor I think
even more significant is this whole
model of you know what the Clinton
Global Initiative was doing was bringing
the billionaire's of the world together
with policymakers and you know you would
have a big announcement from Richard
Branson that he was going to solve
climate change with the profits from his
Airlines and you know this was the
biggest gift in the history of the
Clinton Foundation as a term that turns
out he didn't make good on the promise
of the money or you know certainly
didn't solve climate change but there
was no accountability because unlike
government it's all voluntary and so I
think that model you know Bill Gates has
tremendous power over the u.s. education
system he has tremendous power over
Africa's healthcare system you know he
plays a role that is similar to what the
World Health Organization used to do and
many people argue that he's more
powerful than the World Health
Organization and you know Bill Gates
there's lots of good things in the world
but this idea with the billionaire
Savior complex I think helps create a
context where Donald Trump could stand
before the American people and say
trust me because I'm rich because we had
we were already as a culture acting as
if the ability to make a lot of money in
one area bestowed just kind of infinite
wisdom on this tiny group of
billionaires and and you know even if
they had no experience of health or
education you know they had tremendous
power because of their wealth and so how
different is that from Trump's pitch to
voters of you know sure I don't have any
qualifications and you know any
experience in government but I'm so rich
that you can trust me to to fix America
well you also talked about setting the
stage in terms of going back to Reagan
for example as government being part of
the problem private is the solution then
you talk about the Clinton era and the
deregulation of the banks and then the
failure of President Obama to do
anything to hold the bankers accountable
and how this also set the stage for an
economic system that has allowed the
transfer of wealth to be so enormous Lee
skewed in our society and now you just
have been talking Niomi about the people
who enter into government and maybe you
could talk a little bit about how the
Trump administration has taken it to
extreme where you say they've eliminated
the little of the via the middleman that
you don't have to wine and dine the
people in office anymore because the
corporation's are the ones in office
right now right so once again this is
this is not a process that that Trump
started but he is taking it into new
territory and you know to a point for
instance the CEO of Exxon a Secretary of
State I mean there's certainly been
Secretary of State and US history who
had ties with corporate America you know
Delos you know probably most significant
example Baker I mean it laid this is not
a new new process but but Cheney be the
CEO of Cheney and Cheney or Cheney very
significantly right and I think the
biggest difference is one of optics now
Halliburton was a company that most
people hadn't heard of before but before
Cheney right it's a hugely important
company but it's not a highly branded
company so so appointing the CEO of
Exxon which is really not only a highly
branded company but what is the most
controversial companies in the world
under investigation by three States
Attorneys General over allegations that
it had misled its shareholders about how
much it knew about climate change
because because Exxon had Exxon's own
scientists have been researching the
reality of climate change back in the
70s and 80s and then funded climate
change denial and in the 1990s Exxon was
was was under a lot of pressure when
Trump appointed the CEO of Exxon Rex
Tillerson who'd been at Exxon his entire
working life had never worked anywhere
but Exxon worked there for 41 years and
and so it is a continuation of all of
that Excel that rode that same road you
know from Dulles to Cheney
tu-tu-tu-tu-tu-tu Tillerson and of
course Trump himself because at least
Tillerson divested from Exxon before
becoming Secretary of State at Trump has
just merged it seems the Trump
Organization with the White House except
as you talked about so eloquently in the
book this is now the ultimate giveaway
to corporate America so maybe we should
talk about how the initial I mean we're
not even six months into this
administration and what has this
administration been doing to go through
the top a wish lists of the fossil fuel
companies of the bankers of the
military-industrial complex what are the
what are the items we already see that
has pleased corporate America sure yeah
yeah I mean and and I do think this
should be getting a lot a lot more
attention media because there's a
lot of focus on exposing what what some
people believe is is it is a conspiracy
between the Trump administration and the
Russians and surely that should be
investigated but there is also a kind of
a conspiracy in plain sight I mean there
is this systematic and orderly transfer
of wealth from the lower and middle
incomes to the 1% of the 1% it really is
the connective tissue of everything that
the Trump administration is doing on the
economic front so you know if you look
at the 15 percent corporate tax that
Trump has announced that he wants to
introduce obviously this is a massive
gift to all of corporate America getting
rid of the estate tax you know it's
something that the only benefits the
very wealthy and has been on the wish
list of major Republican donors for a
very long time Trump may be the one that
gets it through precisely because so
much attention is focused on what Trump
in the 80s called the Trump show I said
the show is Trump and it's sold out
everywhere and that was when he turned
his extramarital affair with Marla
maples into a live-action soap opera he
has always understood the power of
distraction now I think some of the
Trump show now is being orchestrated by
Trump I think he likes to leak
information about his palace dramas of
course much of it is being foisted on
him and he clearly does not like the
investigation the Russia investigation
but all of this is drawing our eyes away
from what is happening on the economic
front if we look at what he's doing on
climate it's a huge giveaway to the oil
gas and coal industry the the
deregulation I mean something -
something like in one of the first
things he did was a rollback Obama's
initiative to increase fuel efficiency
standards another one of his very early
too
was to go after new requirements
introduced at the end of the Obama
administration to a better document
methane methane leaks in the gas
industry because we actually don't know
the extent to which the gas industry in
particular fracking is leading to a
major spike in methane emissions because
it's really not tracked very well so
there was new new measures that
companies were going to have to abide by
and this is one of the first things that
Trump has moved to eliminate very very
profitable it also means that we will
not have accurate information about how
much emissions are going up under Trump
so those are a few examples the whole
health care plan that Trump celebrated
in the Rose Garden is a huge giveaway a
backdoor tax giveaway backdoor
redistribution of wealth and I think
it's really unfortunate that we haven't
focused on this enough the budgets
attacks on Social Security and health
care because this really goes against
what Trump promised on the campaign
trail and I do think he is vulnerable
his brand is vulnerable
gulnur broker HAP's out the Trump brand
but the make America great brand had a
very particular promise about bringing
back jobs another another broken promise
another giveaway I think is what we're
going to see with trade Trump promised
to renegotiate NAFTA and other trade
deals so that they would be better for
workers that it would be a new era of
fair trade meanwhile his Commerce
Secretary is reassuring business
audiences that they're going to
renegotiate NAFTA to make it more like
the trans-pacific partnership which is
the deal that Trump that Trump tore up
or withdrew the United States from you
know in one of his first days in office
so if you know this is where I actually
think he's much more vulnerable and you
know unfortunately it's getting a
fraction of the attention it deserves
because the Trump show never stops and
it's always sold out one of the
statistics I loved in your book was the
Trump met with 190 different executives
of corporations in the first three
months in office and then when there
were some news reports about that what
they decided to do is not make public
the list of people who visit the White
House anymore
and I totally agree much of this yeah
yeah I'm going to say that that that the
focus on Russia is taking our eyes off
of so many things on the
military-industrial complex front the
fact that the already bloated Pentagon
budget is now according to Trump not big
enough and when he wants to increase it
with another fifty four billion dollars
and when he announced that the stocks of
the weapons industries just shot up but
there is no attention being paid but
it's more than that
it's more than that media I mean Trump
is basically a traveling weapons
salesman this is what he's this seems to
be the sum total of his foreign policy
he goes to Saudi Arabia he praises them
why because they've just purchased a
whole bunch of US weapons that's who and
he sends a message to the world this is
how you get in America is good good
graces you buy a lot of weapons this is
what Trump likes then so now Qatar has
done the same thing they just announced
a huge new weapons increase and you know
that this is how they're trying to cool
down tensions with Saudi Arabia he goes
to NATO he a NATO summit and he lectures
a NATO members on quote-unquote not
pulling their weight well you know I I'm
a dual Canadian American citizen and and
and and the Canadian Prime Minister went
home and announced the a massive
increase in military spending a 70
percent increase so this is how the
world unfortunately is responding to
Trump they're seeing that the way you
get in the in the good graces of this
administration is by buying it it's by
buying hundreds of millions of dollars
worth of weapons so it isn't just about
the military increase in the United
States its global but let's also do what
you do so beautifully in the book in
setting the stage recognize that it was
under the Obama administration that
countries like Saudi Arabia Saudi Arabia
became the number one weapons purchaser
under Obama who bragged at the White
House website that they had sold 110
billion dollars to this
repressive extremists intolerant
misogynist regime so there again we see
the stage set by the Democrats who
preceded Trump and so here you set the
stage and you talked about people
getting prepared for the shocks to come
but you also talked about what people
are doing to resist Trump now and the
whole premise of your book of no is not
enough does look at what has been done
in the first several months of the Trump
administration with people rising up so
maybe we should spend a little time on
that and then move to why that's not
enough mm-hmm right so we have we have
seen this incredible wave of resistance
and and and we've seen that it can win I
mean the travel ban most notably than
Muslim travel ban and and and that
amazing a surge of people going to
airports across the country and just
saying no just rejecting this and I
think that embolden
local officials and and Congress people
to to also go to the airport lawyers and
you know maybe even giving some courage
to judges to stand up to Trump you know
I so that's one example I think you know
everybody who I know who's involved in
political organizing says is saying that
they've never seen the level of interest
the you know more people showing up to
rally is obviously the women's March you
know from day one record-breaking
numbers of the women's March people want
to get involved they want to understand
their democracy better they're educating
themselves a lot of a lot of white
people trying to do internal work to
understand their own internal racism
showing up more for Rachel for racial
justice and you know this is this is
really inspiring and and I think there's
there's a sort of there's a collective
memory of September 11th and and and and
you know a lot of people described being
in shock that this could happen
trying to respond in ways that deepen
solidarity that make us more shock
resistant and this is really important
because if there is you know heaven
forbid a Manchester like attack in the
United States we already know how Trump
would respond or at least in part
because when a Manchester attacks
happened he immediately blamed
immigrants you said this is about
immigrants flooding across our borders
even though the bomber in that case had
been born in the in the United Kingdom
and after the London Bridge attacks
Trump tweeted that night this is why we
need the travel ban so you know there
are a lot of things that are still on
the Trump agenda some of which have been
stopped by this resistance and some of
which they haven't even tried to do you
know Betsy DeVos is education agenda is
extremely radical she really doesn't
believe in public education and so you
know I'm concerned about a security
shock like Manchester I'm also concerned
about an economic crisis because of
course they're deregulating the banks
they're making it more likely that there
would be another 2008 like crisis and
that would then become the pretext to
privatize social security to attach a
further attack the public education
system and that's why I think it is so
important at for progressives to yes we
have to say no but I think we have to
develop a common agenda
that we are that we will advance when
these shocks hit or even if they don't
need to be advancing a progressive
agenda but one of the things I have
found from covering societies in the
midst of major crisis now for over two
decades is that saying no might be able
to slow it down a little bit but it
really is not enough and you know I
think about being in Greece after the
2008 financial crisis and the ways in
which the Greek people came together you
know very courageously to reject what
they what they saw as being forced to
pay for the crisis of the bankers in
that with with flash wages with
austerity and people occupied plazas and
elected another
government said no what the poll said no
in the streets but there wasn't really
enough of a bold vision for what kind of
economy they wanted instead you know so
I make the case in the book for for us
to do the work to come up with people's
platforms for a forward-looking vision
for real economic racial and
environmental justice that is really
bold that can inspire people because I
think that that's really our best
defense against demagogues who are
tapping into real pain right and mixing
it with some very very insidious ideas
is to hold out that promise of really of
a better life and we saw with the
campaign of Jeremy Corbyn in the UK that
when he issued his his manifesto which
is a very bold document that is about
fully funded public health care that's
about getting rid of tuition fees that's
about a bold transition to renewable
energy and creating huge numbers of
green jobs that is really what inspired
people particularly young people to turn
out in record numbers I think also the
fact that he took on the foreign policy
issues and after there were those
attacks in England rather than just
saying the platitudes he said we have to
look at our policies overseas our
intervention in Libya overthrowing of
Qaddafi and how this creates resentment
and blowback back at home which
unfortunately there are not major
politicians in the United States who
have been willing to say that but that
may change you know I think people are
paying attention to to how how the
atmosphere has shifted
you know when Jeremy Corbyn did that
when he when he when he talked about
those the underlying causes he was
actually absolutely savaged in the
British press and you know his comments
were described as monstrous by Theresa
main stories but it didn't hurt him it
may have helped him because I think
there is at this late stage in the
failed war on terror an appetite for
getting at those root causes just as it
resonated in the United States when
Bernie Sanders talked about climate
change as a security issue and you know
he was mocked up
i buy the sort of elite opinion-makers
but it resonated with a lot of voters
well let's talk a little about the
Bernie Sanders campaign and the kind of
ideas that he talked about that have
become more commonplace and I want to
quote from you you're saying what for
decades was unsayable is now being said
out loud by candidates who win millions
of votes free college tuition double the
minimum wage a hundred percent in
renewable energy demilitarize the police
pria prisons are no place for young
people refugees are welcome here Wars
make us all less safe so could you talk
a little bit about how some of those
ideas have become more acceptable and it
wasn't really from Bernie Sanders
campaign I mean this is this is the the
moment we're in and it's it's an
exciting moment from a progressive
perspective because I mean you know for
me I I grew up in the neoliberal era I
you know my childhood was in the in the
80s the era of Reagan and Thatcher and
there is no alternative and you know
that project was about advancing a set
of radical so-called free market ideas
privatization deregulation cuts the
taxes paid for with cuts to spending
accompanied by huge expansions of the
security state and but but that was sold
on based on the idea that there is no
alternative to it and it was really a
project that would so many ways was
about constraining the collective
imagination and new liberalism that you
know that that echo that set of policies
has been a profound crisis since the
2008 financial financial meltdown for
many reasons not the least of which is
that Elise had to break their own rules
right out you know in in the open and
everybody saw that it was possible to
intervene in the market to save the
banks but suddenly they could find
trillions of dollars after we'd all been
told there was no money for schools no
money
daycares no money for hospitals so that
the spell was broken and and we are in
this period where now the progressive
imagination is being unleashed the first
stage was saying no to the austerity
after the 2008 economic crisis but now
we're the utopian imagination on the
left is being rekindled you see it in
documents like the vision for black
lives which comes out of the Muslim
movement for black lives it's just
really an exciting bold policy document
that is about how to get at the
underlying causes behind police violence
it's really about changing the economy
changing society with racial justice at
the center and I've been involved in a
project called the leap people can read
about it at the leap org which is a
similar intersectional approach but just
as progressive ideas are surging in
popularity and we're saying the
unsayable and candidacies like Bernie's
or jeremy corbyn's
or john mcdonald shaw in france are
doing better than I mean all the entire
expert class predicted it's also the
case that far-right ideas white
supremacist ideas highly xenophobic
ideas are also more popular than they've
been at any point in my lifetime so you
know I see this as a kind of race
against time because when there is this
vacuum where this elite consensus used
to be and as it collapses a lot of
things are shifting
well another contradiction I see is that
the progressive movement is way ahead of
the Democratic Party for example you see
a fight in Baltimore where the people
had won through pushing the City Council
the right to a double to a $15 an hour
minimum wage and the Democratic mayor of
Baltimore then vetoing that so I wonder
what you think about how to move the
Democratic Party that is supposed to be
more progressive and yet doesn't seem to
have caught up to the popular sentiment
and a lot of these issues
so I mean the energy is huge out there
with more and more you know deep
progressive committed to to taking power
and seeing that it is possible I think
with Bernie's campaign you'll Bernie
getting 13 million boats carrying 22
states that there there is really the
belief out there that you know I did not
have you know at any point in my
lifetime up till now which is that a
winning progressive coalition is really
within reach it is possible and you know
we know that Bernie had weaknesses that
he you know that many women of my knee
and your generation didn't feel
comfortable that he really got the how
precarious many women's rights are many
people involved in racial justice issues
didn't feel that he's fully integrated a
racial justice agenda into his campaign
although he got better as the campaign
went on but it would but it was it
wasn't enough to really capture well it
you know and he if he had been able to
capture 50 percent of the black vote in
key states he would have he would have
been able to win so it isn't that you
know the Democratic base is to
right-wing is that there were key
constituencies that he wasn't able to
reach and I think that if that changed
next time around that winning coalition
is out there and people know it and
they're you know I think if the
Democratic Party does not come to its
senses and keeps trying to fight off the
tide of history then people will leave
the party you know this is what I'm
hearing and you know there there's very
much as a live debate about this if we
look at what happened in the UK I mean a
Jeremy Corbyn was fought by his own
party at every single turn he won the
leadership and then he was sabotaged by
his own MPs he faced an internal coup
where they tried to unseat him as leader
and he held on and now after the
election results which were so
surprising which we're you know he won I
believe 32 seats when he was supposed to
have been wiped out people are having to
admit that this is actually the way to
win elections and we'll see what
the Democratic Party learns from that or
not but I don't think it's going to come
come easily I think the lesson of the
corbin campaign is that it's going to be
a fight and there are some people who
think that it's not even worth fighting
within the Democratic Party and and
we'll see yeah it's a tough one because
there are so many other examples in
Europe where it hasn't been
transformation from within traditional
parties it's actually been new parties
that have cropped up that have captured
the public imagination and won
tremendous victories whether it's
podemos in Spain or the examples of
Sarita and Greece or the progressive
parties in in in France or in Portugal
so who knows how it will go the hard
thing in the United States is that we
have this winner-take-all system that
makes it so did I've been really hard
part that's a really hard part I think
if there if there if there was a
different electoral system that allowed
for coalition governments it would be a
bit of a no-brainer in terms of starting
a new party given how much resistance
there is but this is the system that
there is here so not only you brought up
the issue of race and you talk about it
quite a lot in the book you talk about
the movement for black lives and you
also talk about the indigenous community
and of course in Canada you have a very
strong indigenous community that's been
on the forefront of a lot of the
environmental struggles and you have a
very compelling chapter in the book
about your experience at Standing Rock
and I think your view about how we move
to a different society is one where
people of color and the wisdom of
indigenous communities has to be in the
lead so how did you come to that
conclusion well you know I guess I'm you
know I'm a journalist
first and foremost and you know this
book comes from talking to a whole lot
of people in movements who are
organizing and and you know this is you
know this is the wisdom of our movement
at this point this is where the energy
of organizing is you know in Canada you
know every single key environmental
battle has always
been led by indigenous people and you
know this is true to a large extent in
the United States as well that chapter
on Standing Rock I wrote because it was
you know was so moving to be there when
I was there which was when the Obama
administration finally denied the
easement
but Trump had already won the election
and so you know people understood that
this victory was really on borrowed time
that that Trump was going to go in and
probably reverse it but you know the
reason why I wanted to include that
experience in the book is because the
the kind of leadership that I saw in
Standing Rock and and the people that I
spoke to like LaDonna brains'll Allard
Cody to Bears campus Standing Rock Sioux
councilmember chase iron eyes you know
the analysis was so deeply holistic and
intersectional right that this was a
racial justice battle that the that the
pipeline had originally been routed
through through Bismarck an
overwhelmingly white City and had been
rejected because of concerns over water
quality so it was moved to get to this
to underneath the single drinking water
source for the Standing Rock Sioux a
just absolutely classic example of
environmental racism so that was one
piece of it and but it was it was also
very much about climate change and and
understanding that we cannot keep
expanding the fossil fuel frontier and
have any hope of protecting a livable
planet for our kids and and it was also
profoundly about standing up to
corporate power about standing up to
increasingly militarized police because
of course the water protectors at
Standing Rock were up against police
force that looked like an army tanks and
all the privatized surveillance
equipment and tricks and so you know and
I quote Winona LaDuke in the book about
how it's just it was all of it and you
know you can talk about
intersectionality which is a wonderful
phrase from kimberlé crenshaw
african-american legal scholar
and feminist who has given us this term
that so many of us are using and but you
know in Standing Rock it it was just
life it was and I think it's helpful you
know sometimes to not talk about
something in theory but to talk about it
as a lived experience and how it is
playing out on the land and on people's
bodies which you also bring up in the
Standing Rock chapter in which I saw
myself having travelled there is that it
sure was about winning the rights to the
land and to do what they want with their
property but it was also showing a
different way of living together and how
this was an experience that profoundly
changed the people who came to see what
it was like to be in a struggle under
the leadership of the indigenous people
and how different that is than many
other struggles have been the profound
sense of connection to the land even the
language of water protectors not
protesters and do you think that this
will carry on or or have had an impact
on people who were part of this movement
I think everyone who is there was
changed by it and and you know if the
Standing Rock also really embodied the
the title of the book no no is not
enough because as soon as the victory
was won to stop the pipeline it was a it
was a temporary victory as we know but
it's not over and you know that they
also want an important legal victory
that what the Trump has done in pushing
through this pipeline without proper
environmental assessment is illegal so
they haven't stopped fighting but but
but as soon as that that ruling came
down from the Army Corps of Engineers
immediately everybody who I talked to
wanted to say okay now the real work
starts now we can turn this reservation
into a shining example of a justice
based transitions off of fossil fuels we
want to get to a hundred percent
renewable energy we want to start
building the economy that would never
need a new oil pipeline and so it was
like the no the no was necessary to be
able to get to yes right and I think
that this is sort of where we are we
have to weave the no and the yes
together and and that was so inspiring
and in terms of you know how this plays
out I mean the truth is we don't know
and I've been involved in social
movements for long enough to never
believe a movement obituary
you know our movements are always
declared over you know whether it's
Occupy Wall Street whether it's the
so-called anti-globalization movement
but you know those of us who've been
involved in these struggles know that
that that the infrastructure the ideas
the teaching with people that were part
of earlier movements resurface tree
emerge learn from past mistakes so you
know I don't think movements die they
they they go into a period of gestation
and re-emerge and turn into something
else right Occupy Wall Street turned
into occupy sandy responding to
Hurricane sandy and then many many
people from Occupy went on to form the
digital backbone of Bernie Sanders's
campaign and and are continuing to learn
new lessons share information and
involve so you know we just don't know
where those teachings go well I want to
also emphasize that in your book while
you're not naive about how dangerous the
Trump administration is I love the
analogy you use to being in those
automatic tennis things where you're
being hit by the balls constantly and
you're taking a swing and you might get
one or two but you feel like you're
always being battered on the other hand
you talk about the that the Trump agenda
is not all controlling and the Trump
space is not all controlling I just want
to read from this part where you say
they don't control what cities and
states do they don't even control what
Congress does a lot of the time they
certainly don't control universities
faith institutions unions they don't
control what the courts do yet you have
in parentheses they don't control what
other sovereign nations do and they
not control what we do as individuals
and groups around the world and for me
this was very inspiring the section of
the book because you do lay out for us
that we have a lot of spaces in which we
do not have to just be saying no no no
but where we are building up these
alternatives whether it's on the very
small level of the way you live your
life or whether it's on the global level
of how we can reignite some of the
global alliances that we've had in the
past after Bush after Trump said no to
the Paris agenda how the world community
came together to say we are moving ahead
anyway so can you talk a little about
those bases that Trump does not control
right and I think specifically because
what what what Trump and you know his
administration are doing is so dangerous
with what they do control and what they
control is significant the onus on us to
do more in all of these note untrim
facade spaces is all the greater I guess
I started thinking about this when I was
I was speaking I was speaking at Harvard
and you know giving a lecture early on
in the administration and there has been
an absolutely a ferocious fight at
Harvard over fossil fuel divestment
Harvard has one of the strongest fossil
fuel divestment movements in the country
but the administration has been really
intransigent with them and it's really
important for the the fossil fuel
divestment movement because of course
Harvard is so iconic and if Harvard were
to make the decision it would help other
schools and other institutions to also
make a similar decision and talking to
some of the activists there I really
realized that that that that that the
arguments of during the Obama years that
the school used to make was you know
well we don't really think divestment is
it is the most effective way to fight
climate change
we think it's more effective to have
policy and and there was a credible
possibility right that the Obama
administration would introduce policy
that
that would be you know quite strong they
introduced the clean power plan which
was not strong enough but you know what
it wasn't nothing
of course it's being undone by Trump and
because there is no credible prospect at
this moment of a federal legislation on
climate change of a real carbon tax
for instance that that argument is gone
and anywhere where we do have power we
have to use it and during the DNC when
when Michelle Obama said when they go
low we go high right I think that you
know that was probably the best line of
the convention she was talking about
tone and not wanting to join a Trump and
and his gang in the gutter of slurs and
attacks I think we should adopt that
similar approach but as it relates to
policy as it relates to action as as a
trump administration lowers the bar as
they go rogue we have to raise the bar
everywhere where we have power and you
know I think an amazing example this was
the mayor of Pittsburgh after Trump
announced the Paris withdrawal and
invoked the city of Pittsburgh saying he
was he was elected by the people of
Pittsburgh not the people of Paris the
next day you have the mayor of
Pittsburgh stepping up and saying well
actually Pittsburgh voted for Hillary
and you know I'm going to get the city
to 100% renewable energy by 2035 which
is the most ambitious target in the
country I think Portland is the only
other city that has adopted a target
that ambitious so that's an example of
what I mean of people using the power
that they do have to to advance a
powerful progressive vision I think
we're seeing something similar with
healthcare in California the California
Senate moving one step closer to
single-payer precisely because what
Congress and Trump are doing in health
care is so dangerous and I think Emidio
we may well be in a position to advance
something similar when it comes to free
trade I mean when they are seriously
renegotiating NAFTA to make it more like
the TPP that's going to be an opening
for you know for workers movements for
environmentalists for everybody
concerned about
economy to come forward and say no this
is how you write a fair trade agreement
this is what it would look like and you
know really say what we think it would
look like because when we were fighting
these deals back in the day we were
pretty good at saying no but we weren't
as good at saying yes well as we're
winding down now in Iommi I just want to
as an activist one thank you for saying
now the lines are blurred that we have
to all be activists and to giving us
this beautiful way of looking at the
Trump agenda not as something that is so
enormous that we don't want to get out
of bed in the morning because we don't
even want to think about it but as a
challenge to us that we have to take
extremely seriously but that gives us a
lot of not only spaces within which to
work but whole new communities to work
with and I think as you go forward on
your book tour getting more and more
people excited about being part of these
solutions and showing the enormous
potential that these solutions have we
as a community as a nation and as a
global community will be much much
better at articulating the yes that we
want to live in and so thank you so much
for the work the book again no is